ABHI YADAV: Hello, and
welcome to the next breakout
session in security.
In this session, we take
you through a deep dive
in solving a critical
but often hard
to accomplish security
objective of least privilege.
My name is Abhi Yadav.
I'm a product manager at
Google for Identity and Access
Management, and today,
I'm excited to share
with you Google's
latest innovation in IAM
called Policy Intelligence.
And joining me today
is a brilliant panel.
First, we have Vandy
who's a product manager
and researcher at Google
working in Policy Intelligence.
Hi, Vandy.
VANDHANA RAMADURA: Hi, Abhi.
Hi, everyone.
ABHI YADAV: And later joining
us is Guillaume Blaquiere
who's a Certified
Expert in Google Cloud
and also the lead
architect of Veolia,
an organization with more
than 170,000 employees.
And he will walk us through
some of Veolia's advanced
tooling and journey in achieving
least privilege in the Cloud.
Now, when I think of
the Cloud, I sometimes
think of this airplane cockpit.
But the Cloud probably
has more knobs and dials
than this cockpit does.
It is rather complicated.
So some customers, like
Veolia, have tens of thousands
of projects in the Cloud,
and these resources
get spun up and down faster than
the security teams can keep up
with them.
Add to this multiple
layers of policy control
and you have a rather
complex security environment.
And even if you have
the right information,
it's fairly difficult to know if
you've made the right decision.
So as a result, in this
environment, maintaining least
privilege is often a challenging
and never ending task,
but failure can have
pretty high consequences.
So at Google, we ran a
study of our customers
and found that 95% of
permissions that are given
were never used.
So over-provisioning is
a real common problem,
and a threat when
somebody you think
should just have read
access also has the ability
to take down production.
And there are several
factors causing this.
There's a lack of visibility to
understanding how well policies
are configured, understanding
effective access effectively,
weak governance and oversight
that leads to practices
like model after
that go unchecked,
and the elastic
nature of Cloud that
makes it more
difficult to audit,
often leading you
to carry over access
from previous assignments.
Now, ideally, you want to
construct your policies
in a way that you reach a state
of measurable least privilege,
where you limit the attack
surface by granting users
only the permissions they
need at the time they need it.
But we've seen that
customers often
hesitate about changing
their policies because they
don't want to break anything.
But this exposes them to
risk, and generally, people
tend to underestimate
the risk they're in.
I think it's just human nature.
So our goal here
in this entire area
is to give you a better
understanding of the policies
you have and to help you
manage them at scale,
so you can balance the trade-off
between security and developer
velocity.
After all, our
customers come to us,
tell us that the
promise of Cloud
is that we shall make
your security better,
just like ours.
So we want to help
you understand
where you are exposed and
how you can design better
so you don't get breached.
So if you are a security
professional concerned
about this, like
Steve here, here
are some practical and
prescriptive guidance
from Google on how you
should think about achieving
for least privilege.
So Steve needs to
ensure that access
is appropriate to business need,
and reach a goal at the end
where policy
management is scalable,
it's timely, and effective.
So let's look at some of Steve's
challenges and blind spots.
First, how does Steve define
what is appropriate access?
To begin with, he needs to
know what users have access
to today.
Then, to scope it down,
what's safe to remove?
Steve could do this
through trial and error,
but that's time-consuming.
And how do you know what
users will need in the future?
Secondly, how do you get a
good understanding of risk
without being an expert in
Google Cloud, of course.
Steve is concerned about
buckets being exposed
to the internet or the risk of
a service that can be misused
for lateral movement.
Over-accounting
can also be caused
by simple, unintentional
human error that can also
result in data loss or
infrastructure changes that
are often hard to revert.
Now, after you solve
all these problems,
how do you change your
policies in a way that is safe
so it doesn't break
anything in production,
and that scales, so
that Steve, and you,
can do this uniformly across
the organization using code?
And lastly, Steve needs to make
sure that this is measurable
so he can report back that
he is moving the organization
towards least privilege.
Now, all of this is obviously
much easier said than done.
At Google, we believe
that solving this problem
by just hiring and
staffing cybersecurity
experts in today's world
is not a scalable solution
to these problems.
We believe the answer lies in
intelligence and automation.
And so we built our product,
Policy Intelligence,
to assist users as they move
through the lifecycle of policy
management to manage this policy
securely and with confidence.
And we do this by fusing
the magic of Google,
which is data, machine
learning, throughout your Cloud
experience.
A way to think about this
is think about the way cars
have evolved.
Today's cars kind of seem
like the car on the left.
It's manual and unguided.
And we want to upgrade the
experience like modern cars
and beyond with
the help of tools
that we provide to make
your security much better.
So we want to effectively
take policy management
through this same upgrade
to achieve intelligence
and automation, like
we did with cars.
So we asked
ourselves, what can we
do to empower our
customers in this way?
And after speaking
with many of you,
we found that the answers
were clearly in three areas.
First, you want to find
out what went wrong quickly
so you take action right away
with troubleshooting tools.
Secondly, you want
to prevent mistakes
from happening altogether
with analytical tools.
And thirdly, you want to
improve your Cloud easily
with actionable recommendations.
Now to talk to you and
walk through these products
in details, I'll hand it over
to Vandy for a deep dive.
VANDHANA RAMADURA: Thanks, Abhi.
So let's start with
Policy Troubleshooter.
We designed it to make it super
easy for you to understand
why a user doesn't have access.
When you're in the midst
of doing something,
it's frustrating to
see an error message
and not know what to do
next, especially when
you expect your policies
have been set up correctly.
This might seem
like a simple issue,
but it can be surprisingly
hard to troubleshoot.
Without Troubleshooter,
you'd have
to scan all the policies across
the hierarchy one by one.
You'd have to find the policy
that allows the API call.
And if that policy
has a group, you'd
need to manually check if
the user is in the group.
All of this takes a lot
of time, and our customers
don't want security to be
in the way of productivity.
So admins like
Steve would usually
unblock their developers
by granting them
overly permissioned roles
just so they're not blocked.
Now, with self-service tools,
like Policy Troubleshooter,
a developer can hit Troubleshoot
when they see an error message
and share the URL of the
Troubleshooter to Steve.
The error message automatically
passes the principle, resource,
and permission.
Policy Troubleshooter will show
you all the relevant policies
across the hierarchy
so admins like Steve
can make a decision
on the best place
to grant the developer access.
It helps Steve
understand which roles
are needed to unblock
this developer,
and also helps
you make decisions
on where in the
hierarchy to grant roles.
At times, a user might even
be blocked because they're not
a member of the right
group, and Troubleshooter
can help you figure this out.
Troubleshooter also highlights
dynamic access control issues,
such as when
conditions are applied.
For example, a developer
might get an error
if she access as a
resource after 5:00 PM,
and Troubleshooter
will easily tell
Steve the issue is the user did
not meet the time condition.
With Policy
Troubleshooter, Steve now
feels that he's in a position
to not only establish
the principle of
least privilege,
but actually maintain it instead
of simply granting overly
permissive roles to
everyone who comes
to him with "my access isn't
working" type of issues.
So here are some ways you can
use Policy Troubleshooter.
If you're not sure if
a service account that
is buried in a group
can reach a resource,
Troubleshooter will show
you group membership
even for nested groups.
Designed as an admin
self-service tool,
you can integrate this into
your helpdesk tools like Jira.
And we're excited
to announce we're
extending this to support VPC
Service Controls and Identity
Aware Proxy errors.
While Steve was troubleshooting
for his developer,
he was surprised to see owner
roles assigned on his project.
So Policy Analyzer
is our query tool
that can help you reduce
your organizational risk
through improved visibility.
If you're looking
to understand who
has access to what, what
does that access secure,
and what are users
doing with that access,
you can do so efficiently
with Policy Analyzer.
Steve quickly uses
Policy Analyzer
to find out who has the owner
role in his organization
and where it was granted.
He selects the owner
role and does the query.
In the results, Steve can now
see members who have this role.
With Policy Analyzer, Steve is
able to answer this question
and many more.
In addition to this
one he had in mind,
he runs a couple
of other queries.
Which VMs can John delete?
Who has write access on
this BigQuery data set?
It feels like magic.
If you're wondering how
someone's access will change
when they move from
one group to another,
use Policy Analyzer to
understand access impact.
Also use it to query
and create reports
for privilege escalation
and access certification.
And if you're wondering what
changed in a policy and when,
use Policy Analyzer
to understand
the history of your policies.
But before Steve
changes the order role,
he wants to make sure he
doesn't break anything.
With Policy Simulator, Steve
can check the proposed policy
changes against the 90-day
access history of the user
to see if the changes would
block any essential access that
was previously used.
Steve knows Anita often
works in BigQuery.
So he changes Anita's owner
rule to BigQuery admin.
Policy Simulator shows
which permissions
would have been [? usually ?]
granted with a BigQuery admin
role, and which permissions
would be revoked.
With Policy Simulator's
results, Steve
can the impact of the change and
ensure Anita's productivity is
not impacted.
These analytical tools, like
Troubleshooter, Analyzer,
and Simulator, can
help you figure out
what your current
state policies are.
Then we have tools,
like the Recommender,
to give you proactive
guidance on how
to achieve these privilege.
And to tell you about this,
I'll hand it back to Abhi.
ABHI YADAV: Thank you, Vandy.
That was great.
So we introduced IAM Recommender
last year at Next 2019
to help customers achieve least
privilege with least effort.
And since then, we are
super excited that thousands
of customers around the world
are using this every day
to minimize their
attack surface.
Now, this product helps security
and nonsecurity professionals
identify unneeded access to GCP.
Using machine learning, we
provide smart access control
recommendations.
Right here in the IAM
page, the Recommender
is going to show you how
many permissions are given
and how many are
actually being used.
There's no need to collect and
pass through activity loads.
We've done all that
hard work for you.
In the back end, we store and
process petabytes of log data
daily at no additional
charge to our customers.
We now simply show you
this data and these results
right here next to the
user's role assignment.
Now, it looks like most of
the members in my project
here are OK.
There are a few that are using
a lot less than were granted.
And you can see three
light bulbs have popped up.
This is where our
ML models have found
a recommendation for
a better fitting goal
automatically, in
the back ground.
I had to do no work.
Now, this service
account on the top row
has owner role with about
1,800 permissions assigned,
but it has used only 31 of them.
So now, IAM Recommender
is going to tell me
that I should change its role
to reduce the attacks efforts.
And if I need, I can
click to get more details.
So here the tool
shows me the analysis
behind the recommendation.
It suggests the service account
should be moved to the BigQuery
admin role and why
by highlighting
the permissions here that
are safe to remove in red.
ML also picks out
that this account
would need the
saved queries update
permission in the future based
on similar usage patterns.
Now, this is a permission
it already has,
but that it has not yet used.
And you can find this marked
anywhere with the blue ML icon.
So we do this because we want to
make sure that users or service
accounts don't miss
out on permissions
and don't have to come
back later to request more.
And now, in our
latest update, we
have also added
the ability for you
to customize the recommendation.
If you want to remove a
permission or add one,
you can do that right here
in the recommendations screen
in context, which
creates a custom role.
And now your custom
role would be
based on actual activity data
and improved with Google ML
to suggest which permissions you
need to add based on observed
patterns in the Cloud.
So you just need to hit apply,
and that would make the change,
creates a custom
role, and assigns it
to the service account.
And now, this custom
role would be recommended
to other members as needed.
Another area we have
invested in this year
is making recommendations
easier to discover.
So project teams can
self-serve in the Cloud,
in the Cloud console
in the IAM page,
as we have shown you already.
Now, they can also
find recommendations
in our recommendation hub that
is located in the Cloud console
dashboard.
Here, project teams can
give you the right insights
and the recommendations
and apply them
if they have the permission.
Secondly, for central
security teams,
we now support out of the box
integration with BigQuery.
So with a few simple
steps, you can
export all your
recommendations to a VQ table.
Now this will allow you to
create all the right custom
reports.
So for example, if you want
a view of over-provisioning
across your
production workloads,
or if you want to analyze a
given permission for a service
account, you can do that
very easily here using
our analytical tools.
And lastly, we expose
insights and recommendations
through APIs with methods
such as get, clean,
mark as succeeded.
So in addition to
automating recommendations,
we've also have some
customers use this
to create alerts and reminders.
So maybe they are
sending weekly digest
to the project
teams alerting them
that they should take action.
So here are some ways
that you can get started
with IAM Recommender today.
Number one, to protect
against lateral movement,
we recommend a defense
in depth strategy.
A key piece of this
approach includes
limiting members who have the
act ask permission on projects,
as well as service accounts.
So you can use IAM Recommender
to ensure that users are not
assigned a service account
user role at the project level.
Also, you can use
the Recommender
to understand where service
accounts have permissions
across projects.
So for example, if a service
account that is in project A
has been granted a
role in Project B,
you can use Recommender
to understand
where these can be removed
to mitigate lateral movement
threats.
Secondly, just don't use
owner and editor legacy roles.
These are not recommended.
And you can use IAM
Recommender today
to scope down the access
to more granular roles.
Our product now provides
a migration path
from these legacy roles to
multiple and smaller roles,
which is best practice.
So you can go from
a large owner role
to more fine grained roles.
And lastly, as you
saw earlier, you
can use this feature to create
meaningful custom roles based
on activity data, actual
activity data, and machine
learning.
And lastly, I'd like to
share with you some pro tips.
If you have, like many
of your customers,
thousands of projects
and recommendations,
do start with developing
a prioritization strategy
and a framework to
identify the severity
of these recommendations in
the context of your Cloud
environment so you
can understand which
ones you want to apply first.
Think about exporting
these recommendations
to your existing IGA or
access certification tools,
and this will help speed up your
resource owner or user manager
certifications.
And you can use these
recommendations with insights
to understand what access
a user has across projects.
And lastly, when
using our APIs, don't
forget to mark recommendations
as succeeded, as when you have
applied them, this will
help you track your progress
towards least privilege.
So now I'm super excited
to introduce Guillaume
to talk about Veolia's journey
in using policy intelligence
to achieve least privilege.
Veolia is one of Google Cloud's
largest customers in the world.
They have been using
it for a long time
and they have thousands
and thousands of projects.
And they've also been providing
us feedback from early stages
and have been an
advocate in shaping
the direction of our products.
Thank you, Guillaume.
ABHI YADAV: Thank you for
sharing that, Guillaume.
It's so lovely to see
customers like Veolia
who use these tools in
such interesting ways.
So we are very
excited to announce
that Policy Intelligence is now
part of Active Assist, a brand
new solution from Google Cloud.
Active Assist is a
solution that focuses
on reducing complexity
in your Cloud environment
and providing you with a variety
of intelligent and proactive
features, many of which are
based on machine learning.
By using the capabilities
of Active Assist,
you are empowered to focus
more on your business
and less on Cloud
administration.
Active Assist
offers capabilities
from members across
multiple IT teams,
whether it's compute and
storage, or networking,
or security like us, and custom
billing management, et cetera,
et cetera.
By using Active
Assist, your teams
can use their
capabilities to help
them do many things like
reducing and minimizing waste
by provisioning VMs precisely
or realizing discounts
fully, elevating your
security posture with tighter
permissions and clear and
functional firewall rules,
and minimizing toil
across the board
by identifying and fixing
issues rapidly, and testing
configurations before you
commit them, all of which
frees up time savings and more
important endeavors for you
to chase, like
business innovation.
And long story short,
Active Assist is here to,
well actively assist you.
And we want to help
you focus on your goals
by using intelligence and
automation to vastly reduce
the time you spend on
Cloud administration.
Now if you would like
to learn some more,
check out our new website at
cloud.google.com/activeassist,
and attend our two
breakout sessions, CMP 100.
And if you'd like to
learn more about IAM
Recommender in a
deep dive session
attend our breakout
session SCC 216.
Thank you very
much for your time.
Hope you enjoyed
this session today.
And happy IAMing.